getting hair and makeup done isn't
always glamorous especially when it
comes to zombie productions from the
unconventional prosthetics to the wounds
inspired by medical photos to the
realistic details brought to life the
all of us are dead team nailed it in
bringing the creepy and gory zombie
aesthetic to our screen how did they do
it watch on and we'll tell you if we
make it out will we really be living
they didn't wake up looking like this
this makeup done on the actors and all
of us are dead doesn't do them justice
but it does do their zombie versions
justice looking as realistically decayed
as can be to help bring the realistic
zombie vibe to life a lot of specially
made facial prosthetics were used on the
face as a base
each individual piece would be added
secured but that was just the beginning
makeup came next to blend the
prosthetics in and then the fun stuff
all the creepy bits of effects whether
the makeup artists were adding coloring
to the wounds to make them look real or
adding some fake blood as a final touch
it was a detailed process that resulted
in the actors spending a load of time in
the makeup chair but it brought these
incredible results making all that time
and effort very much worth it
that was crazy
it wasn't just the zombies who were
looking rough whether or not they had
yet to become zombies the students who
were caught in the crossfire of the
takeover in the school suffered their
fair share of injuries and cue those
special effects makeup artists that
bring all those rough looks to life with
all the action that happens in the show
it's no surprise these students are
meant to be totally battered and bruised
meaning those makeup blemishes were
applied all over the body from their
faces to their feet
quiet
don't make any noise
need an injury there's a prosthetic for
that we're discovering that there's
pretty much a prosthetic for everything
but what's special about all of us are
dead is just how well those prosthetic
pieces were blended onto the actors
faces and bodies whether it was multiple
small pieces or one massive built
prosthetic covering half of their face
the makeup team focused on blending it
all together well enough to amp up the
hyperrealism while the prosthetics
helped show the realities of a zombie
attack it did make the actors jobs
trickier leaving them acting through
their prosthetics and making sure their
performance matched up with the level of
their impressive makeup that's right
okay are you ready
i'm not let's go
the makeup process wasn't always pretty
actually it never really was but pretty
wasn't the goal they did what they could
in the makeup chair but when things
really needed to get bloody well the
special effects team went full tilt
adding buckets of fake blood until some
performers were literally just lying in
a pool of it who said makeup had to be
glamorous definitely not this crew the
cleaning team had an extra hard job on
this show
[Applause]
when it comes to zombies go big or go
home no matter what part of the body you
looked at on these characters turned
zombies there was a hint of their decay
somewhere small bits of latex were added
by hand by the makeup artists directly
onto the actors bodies resulting in
these bits of flesh that appear to
almost be peeling off small touches like
these helped to show off the more
natural decay of zombies that the team
was hoping for
[Music]
anyone need a tissue
the makeup process did not end in the
makeup trailer instead of keeping these
nosebleeds tidy the all of us our dead
crew brought the mess and it happened to
be kept inside a small syringe
it may look tiny but that piece of
medical equipment full of fake blood
really did the trick getting slipped
into the performer's nose to infuse some
blood for the shot this kind of work was
precise and required the timing to be
spot on as soon as the fake blood was in
place it was a rush to get rolling to
make sure the full progression was seen
from clear face to stream of blood
flowing out of the performer's nostril
now you are it it's not a typical
prosthetic but it works we're talking a
real pylon yeah like the orange plastic
one it was simple but using this pylon
as a kind of prosthetic leg turned out
to be a clever and unexpected detail
when found in this kind of high-stakes
intense situation you've got to work
with what you've got a pylon may not be
a fancy choice on a big show like this
but it makes for a solid prosthetic leg
in a pinch when needed
most of the zombie crew could probably
use a doctor there weren't any doctors
on set but the special effects makeup
artist shinji hey was pretty darn close
wanting to keep the show grounded in
reality there was a major focus on what
medical wounds really looked like
hours were spent researching to settle
on the best way to design all the
injuries check out shin's browser
history and it would be chalk full of
images of everything from congenital
heart conditions blisters sores any
real-life gory stuff that they could get
their hands on looking at various scars
one of the biggest surprises was just
how different they could look and be
from the superficial cuts to the deepest
of scars
using these very real references gave
the special effects makeup a unique and
disturbingly realistic image
[Applause]
where's your zombie from
at first glance we wouldn't guess the
zombies and all of us are dead would
look too different from other zombies
we've seen before
but taking a closer look there are
actually some pretty significant
differences the team on the show
recognized the fact that most zombies
we've seen in film and television before
have looked pretty gaunt with dull skin
and a general evil we're gonna eat your
brains out vibe the korean all of us are
dead zombies say hello to rotting skin
and scar-covered corpses
with all that it comes the signature
gore we've come to know in the series
it's hard to say which version of the
zombies is more effective what we will
say is these ones had us totally freaked
come on
[Music]
they weren't always eating bodies and
brains
this might be the first time we've seen
zombies eating well
human food while this wasn't the most
comfortable it was the best solution
since the makeup process was so
extensive both in the application and
removal once these actors were zombified
there was no turning back until they
were wrapped for the day since they
would have lost way too much time on set
in the in-between
if anything it definitely helped them
stay in character they could even take
advantage of that down time and costume
to practice their zombie eating
or would it be human eating either way
it was messy
is anyone there
anyone
no zombies are allowed to leave the set
picture this the all of us are dead
actors showing up looking fresh they
either get their zombie look or they're
battered in trying to survive a zombie
takeout look spend all day giving it
their all performing on set and at the
end of it in whatever state they were in
each actor was still in charge of
removing their makeup this cow screwed
be very close resulting in makeup and
prosthetic removal parties in their
trailers at the end of each day until
they looked as fresh as they did when
they arrived only a bit more exhausted
after the long day on set
they're all zombies
does this makeup match these clothes
okay so the makeup was one job but
making sure everything else complemented
that work was just as important it was
for that reason that the director
decided the school uniforms should be
made green if all that money time and
effort was going to be put into the gory
makeup it needed to stand out and the
red blood on green did the trick this
was an especially important factor since
over the course of the season the
footage got progressively darker leaving
all the more need to keep that contrast
stark
if you bite me
i'll end up like you they're gory
they're creepy
they make pretty perfect zombies what if
they drop a nuclear bomb
korea doesn't have nukes what are you
saying huh which element of the all of
us are dead makeup and prosthetics
creation surprised you most